hello everyone I hope you enjoyed my
subscribers video if you haven't had the
opportunity to see it there's a link in
the description below feel free to check
it out as seen people from different
parts of the world different countries
different cultures all brought together
by chess is simply amazing if you
enjoyed it you know do share with your
friends share it on social media so
people can see that everyone plays chess
this chess isn't just some weird game
that was played 200 years ago and if you
really enjoyed it feel free to send me
your own photos and videos so I can use
them in my next subscribers video so
thank you for that now let's get back to
this game this is a game from round 10
it was a game that was I think this was
the first game that was finished as it
was a rather short Peter Svidler versus
shock rearmament yarv and it's makes a
blunder that Geary says in his own
interview that happens to a lot of
players and a lot of top grandmasters
because it's simply unavoidable
sometimes this will strike you and you
have to you have to deal with it
so let's see the game it's quite a
theoretical game nothing nothing to it
really but it it explodes very soon so
sweedler opens up the game with c4 the
English opening we have Knight to f6
Knight to f3 and e 6 we have Knight to
c3 d5 and we have d4 now transposing
into the Queens gambit declined
we have Bishop to b4 Dorados in defense
and seek actor son d5e capture son d5
and now Bishop to f4 here mama D arrow
goes for Knight to e4 and is already
threatening some captures here on c3 and
here White has quite a few options he
can block this with Bishop to d2 he can
walk with Knights to d2 he can protect
the night one more time which rook to
see one but silver goes for Queen to a4
check
we have Knight to c6 and the Queen to a4
maybe it's a line I don't know it seems
a bit weird as after Knight to c6 you
haven't really accomplished anything
rook to c1 and now mama D are simply
castles and g3 we have g5 k
in the bishop back Bishop to e3 and now
comes f5 Bishop to g2 Ziggler is ready
to Castle batma madero immediately goes
for f4 we have G captures on f4 and now
before recapturing first Bishop captures
and c3b captors on c3 and now G captures
on f4 kicking the bishop further back
Bishop to e2 and King to H a to making
room a room for this rook on g 8 and
here this is the moment giri was talking
about in his interview the move you want
to consider here is probably something
like c4
maybe rook the g1 getting this rook
ready to defend it the bishop and also
maybe maybe put the bishop away so this
rookie gets the open G file it's
definitely a passive position for white
and you have to be very careful and here
Peter Svidler played Queen to b3 and
this is a pretty terrible blunder as it
allows black to play this nice to a5
move which would a temple on the Queen
Queen has to move and then this night is
coming to c4 and this will be just
terrible
so Queen to c2 by sweedler and now
Knight to c4 and look at these Knights
here they are I mean beautiful squares
for the Knights night and I don't see
for a knight on e4 there's no beep on to
ever kick away this night on c4 or the
deep on this night maybe could be kicked
away with f3 but you know your king is
still anyone yeah you don't want to play
a move like f3
so rook to d1 was played as you do have
to protect that Bishop on d2 so the
knight on f3 can move we have roped a g8
and now comes Knight to e5 other than
Knight to e5 it's I mean there really
aren't any better moves I mean a rope to
g1 maybe but nothing really works for
white here nice to e5 was tried and now
comes Knight captures on e5 and you
can't recapture the night if D captures
only five then rook captures on g2 you
lose the piece but pretty much every
line white loses a piece here so Bishop
captures on e4 and here Queen to g5 by
mamita
you don't you don't need to capture the
bishop I mean you you can't capture it
but it's not necessary if you capture it
then whites white and simply play Queen
captures on e4 and then maybe maybe he
could get some counter play I mean okay
he does have a dark square bishop if he
manages to push c4 and b5 maybe this
Bishop can harass the King a bit but
would correct play this is this is
really bad for white but yeah he
probably played that he can never
capture on e5 then because if he
captures them you get Queen to g5 this
comes with a threat of Queens you want
checkmate after the Queen is captured
and Roco deliver checkmate and you don't
really have a move here Bishop to see
one you get III again you're threatening
Queens you want checkmate
so after this Bishop to e4 move Mammadov
doesn't bother himself with capturing
the bishop he plays Queen to g5
immediately and immediately threatens
going to g1 checkmate
we have Bishop captures on f4 and well I
mean what do you do here if you try
something like Bishop to c1 making room
for the King Bishop to c1 then you get
Knight to c4 now Knight from c4 is
defending be d2 and you're still
threatening Queen Queens you want
checkmate and if rook to f1 Bishop to h3
now attacking the rook and this is game
over and let's not forget your Bishop is
still attacked here on e4
so after this Queen to g5 move Bishop
characters on f4 was played queen
characters on f4 and now Bishop captures
on d5
we have Bishop to a5 attacking the Queen
and in this position Peter Svidler
resigned the game this is move 21 so
quite a quite a miniature by Mahmoud
Yara and let's see why why did he resign
I mean clearly okay it's a better
position for black but is it is it
resigned material well let's check some
of the options your queen is attacked
you have to move it let's try Queen to
d2 you offer a trade of Queens
well here comes Knight to d3 check you
don't really you don't really have any
options here if you go if you move the
king then Queen characters and f2 is
checkmater tonight is protecting the DF
2 square so we probably have to capture
it D captures ich after Sun d3 and now
comes rook a to the 8th check you have
to block this and now Queen to f3
attacking the rook you maybe want to
play rook to f1 although it doesn't
really matter what you play if try to
save the rook now you get Bishop
captures captures and rook captures and
this will lead the checkmate after Queen
to e2
but after Bishop f5 let's try let's try
a different idea let's let's try ìiî ìiî
if black captures your queen you capture
the black Queen on f4 but here actually
Queen to f3 is perfectly fine you
actually attacked the bishop with your
queen as crazy as that sounds
so after Bishop captures Queen Knight
captures an f3 with check King e2 not
simply you capture the Queen it doesn't
really matter what you do King Capra's
f3 now you check the King goes back
Bishop captures rook captures and black
is up a whole rook so definitely if
white is doomed here let's let's check
out Queen B - maybe maybe Queen V - but
now you get a nightcap Knight to g4
again threatening to capture here on f2
and after rook to f1 you get Knight
captures on h2 threatening the knight
the rockin on f1 let's say III now we
get rook to e8 Queen to e2 and let's say
Bishop to g4 now again your rook is
attacked your queen is attacked and
you're still down a piece so this is
completely unplayable so after this
Bishop to a5 move and move 21 this this
pretty neat miniature was created by a
shark dear mama D are off probably I
mean he always had a better position in
this game but that Queen to b3 that
allowed Knight to a5 to c4 was was too
much after that it's it's all downhill
for Beatrice wheeler the the reigning
Russian champion so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it like I said I
definitely suggest you check out the
subscribers video if you enjoy it send
me your own videos your own photos and
there will also be
an email in the description below where
you can finally send me your own games
that were of course played over the
board in a serious tournament you know
there will be a set of instructions in
the subscribers video so yeah that's it
I do hope you enjoyed it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I would like to thank Richard van der
mal Gabrielle tenets Allah Tala
Omar al ty Alamo Moreau Juan Valencia
James Norwood Lucas Freitas John
Lockwood and John Fullmer for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot
to really appreciate it
like I said two of my videos will be
available here the one in the upper left
corner will be the subscribers video so
once again feel free to check it out
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon